>>> IN UKRAINE TONIGHT, RUIAN
INVADERS ARE BEING DRIVEN AWAY
BY INTENSE UKRAINIAN
COUNTEROFFENSIVE WHICH HAS NOW
TAKEN BACK MORE THAN 2300 SQUARE
MILES.
CNN'S SAM KILEY WAS THE FIRST
INTERNATIONAL JOURNALIST TO GO
INSIDE A KEY STRATEGIC CITY JUST
RECAPTURED BY UKRAINIAN FORCES.
HE HAS OUR EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEEN A
STUNNING ADVANCE.
UKRAINE'S ROUT OF RUSSIAN
INVADERS HAS RECAPTURED 6,000
SQUARE KILOMETERS, UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT HAS.
THIS LAND WAS HELD BY RUSSIA
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
NOW IT'S PROVIDING A RICH
HARVEST TO UKRAINE'S ARMY OF
ABANDONED RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT.
THE RUSSIAN Z SYMBOL PAINTED
OVER.
THE GUNS READY TO KILL RUSSIANS.
THE RECAPTURE OF IZYUM, A
STRATEGIC PRIZE, ACCELERATED BY
PRECISION STRIKES FROM NEW
ARTILLERY DONATED BY WESTERN
ALLIES.
THIS WAS CLEARLY HIT WITH A VERY
LARGE PIECE OF ARTILLERY OR AN
AIR STRIKE.
YOU CAN SEE HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS
STRATEGICALLY.
FORMERLY A SCHOOL AS A KIND OF
CHILDREN'S PAINTING ON THE WALL.
BUT IT'S ALSO GOT THESE LARGE
HOLES WHICH HAVE BEEN DUG TO
STORE TANKS OR ARMORED PERSONNEL
CARRIER, OR EVEN ARTILLERY
PIECES.
THERE IS ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR,
FIVE.
WE WERE SHOWN INTO A COMMAND
CENTER IN THE BUNKERS OF AN OLD
FACTORY.
>> SO DOWN HERE WE'VE SEEN A
MEDICAL FACILITY, CALL IT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT INSIDE THIS
BUNKER.
THERE IS A BARRACKS.
>> RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
>> SLEEPING.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: THE TOP BRASS HERE
SLEPT ON BEDS MEDAL OF OLD
DOORS.
AND THE COMMAND CENTER HERE.
AS I WALK ALONG HERE, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY EXTRAORDINARY.
THERE WERE THE DIFFERENT LABELS
FOR THE DIFFERENT ROLES OF THE
SENIOR RUSSIAN OFFICERS ON THESE
SCHOOL DESKS THAT HAVE BEEN
ARRANGED IN THIS BUNKER IN AN
OLD WHAT LOOKS LIKE A BRAKE
FACTORY.
NOW THEY WERE SAFE DOWN HERE
UNDERGROUND, BUT THEY DIDN'T
FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO STAY IN
IZYUM.
AND WHAT'S CRITICAL ULTIMATELY
FOR THE UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES
IS MAKING SURE THAT THE SENIOR
OFFICERS OF THE RUSSIAN ARMY
STAY ON THE RUN.
IF THEY DO THAT, THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES WILL COLLAPSE
COMPLETELY IN UKRAINE AND
POTENTIALLY THREATENED THE
LONGEVITY OF ONE VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Reporter: THIS COUPLE
CELEBRATED LIBERATION.
THEY TOLD ME THAT SOME OF THEIR
NEIGHBORS WERE LESS DELIGHTED
AND HAD BLAMED UKRAINIAN FORCES
FOR SHELLING THEIR HOMES.
BUT HE INSISTED THE INCOMING
SHELLS NEVER HIT THE CHECKPOINTS
OR RUSSIAN ARTILLERY BASED RIGHT
OUTSIDE HIS HOUSE, AND SO BLAMED
THE RUSSIANS FOR FALSE FLAG
ATTACKS ON CIVILIANS.
HE SAID THE RUSSIANS BEHAVED
LIKE PIGS.
THEY STOLE EVERYTHING FROM ALL
THE EMPTY HOUSES BEFORE THEY RAN
AWAY.
THE RUSSIAN GUNS WERE BUSY HERE.
THE WOODEN AMMUNITION BOXES NOW
STOCKPILED FOR WINTER FUEL.
AND TO THE UKRAINIAN VICTORS
HERE, THE SPOILS HAVE BEEN RICH.
THE CAPTURE OF IZYUM AND THE
ROUT OF RUSSIA HERE HAS BROKEN A
KEY LINK IN PUTIN'S LOGISTICS
CHAIN IN THE BATTLE FOR THE
EAST.
NOW YOU HAVE THE REMARKABLE
SCENE OF A TANK COMING TO
COLLECT AN ABANDONED RUSSIAN
HOWITZER.
I ASKED HIM IF IT HAD BEEN A
HARD FIGHT.
♪ NOT REALLY, HE SAID.
THE LATEST UKRAINIAN SUCCESSES
MAY NOT BE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
WAR, BUT NOT EVEN THE KREMLIN
CAN DENY THAT THIS CHAPTER HAS
BEEN A VERY SORRY TALE FOR
RUSSIA.
NOW, WOLF, THE RUSSIAN FORCES
CAN NOW RETREAT IF THEY CHOOSE
TO ENTER THOSE MUCH MORE BETTER
PREPARED POSITIONS THAT THEY'VE
GOT IN THE SEMI INDEPENDENT
SELF-DECLARED AREAS OF DONBAS
THAT THEY CAPTURED IN 2014.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS ALREADY
BEEN HINT THEY WILL HAVE TO
FIGHT BY OTHER MEANS, MORE
MANUFACTURES MORE, SPECIAL
FORCES I SUSPECT.
>> SAM KILEY ON THE SCENE FORCE,
STAY SAFE OVER THERE.
THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH.
AND LET'S DISCUSS WITH THE
UKRAINIAN AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES, OKSANA MARKAROVA.
AMBASSADOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
DOES UKRAINE SEE THESE MAJOR
MILITARY ADVANCES BY UKRAINE AS
A MAJOR TURNING POINT IN THIS
WAR?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S 202nd DAY OF THE WAR, AND
THIS COUNTEROFFENSIVE WHICH
ALREADY ALLOWED US TO FREE MORE
THAN 2500 SQUARE MILES OF
UKRAINIAN TERRITORY, AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, ALMOST 300 VILLAGES
AND DIFFERENT SETTLEMENTS, AND
OUR PEOPLE THERE, IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR TURNING POINTS, I THINK
THE MOST ONE AFTER WE HAVE FREED
THE KYIV OBLAST.
SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT STILL.
THE FIGHT THAT RUSSIANS ARE
PUTTING UP OF COURSE WHEN
THEY'RE NOT RUNNING IS PRETTY
BIG.
AND ESPECIALLY THEY'RE DOING
VERY COWARDLY ATTACKS ON OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND JUST STILL
SHOOTING AT THE CIVILIAN
BUILDINGS, PLACES, EVERYWHERE.
BUT IT'S A BIG MOMENTUM WHEN WE
HAVE SHOWN THAT WE CAN WIN.
>> VERY IMPRESSIVE MILITARY
ADVANCES INDEED.
AMBASSADOR, UKRAINIANS IN ONE
LIBERATED VILLAGE TOLD CNN'S SAM
KILEY THAT THE RUSSIAN, AND I'M
QUOTING NOW, LOCKED PEOPLE IN
BASEMENTS AND BEAT THEM.
PROSECUTORS, AS YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING REPORTS OF
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS BEING
TORTURED AND KILLED BY THE
RUSSIANS.
WHAT DO YOU FEAR RUSSIA HAS
LEFT IN ITS WAKE?
>> YES, WOLF.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE SEE HERE AND
WE ONLY START UNCOVERING THIS
TRAGIC ACCOUNTS.
WE SEE EXACTLY WHAT WE SAW IN
BUCHA, IRPIN AND OTHER PLACES
AFTER WE LIBERATED THOSE AREAS
FROM THE OCCUPATION.
HERE PEOPLE WERE UNDER
OCCUPATION FOR MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS, AND WE ALREADY SEE
ACCOUNT OF TORTURES AND DEATH
AND ATTACKS ON THE KIDNAPPINGS.
SO UNFORTUNATELY, WE SEE THE
SAME WAR CRIMES AND ATROCITIES.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO INCREASE
OUR EFFORT.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO FREE AND
LIBERATE OUR TERRITORIES AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THE WAR COUNCIL
AND WAR CRIMES AND MORE CALL FOR
JUSTICE ON EVERYTHING THE
RUSSIANS ARE DOING ON THIS
TERRITORY WHICH ARE ILLEGALLY
AND TEMPORARILY OCCUPIED.
>> USE KNOW, AMBASSADOR, UKRAINE
IS NOW ASKING THE UNITED STATES
FOR MORE WEAPONS TO SUSTAIN THIS
MILITARY MOMENTUM THAT'S GOING
ON.
YOU WANT MORE DRONES, TANKS, A
LONGER RANGE MISSILE SYSTEMS.
HOW CRITICAL IS IT FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO TAILOR ITS
WEAPONS PACKAGES FOR UKRAINE TO
THIS NEW STAGE OF THE WAR?
>> IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
SUSTAIN THE EFFORT, AS MILITARY
PEOPLE SAY.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND I THINK THE SUCCESSES IN THE
SOUTH AND EAST ARE RESOLVED.
OF COURSE, BRAVERY AND MASTERY
OF OUR MILITARY FORCES.
BUT ALSO, UNBELIEVABLE AND
TIMELESS SUPPORT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
PRESIDENT, TO CONGRESS, TO ALL
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR THIS.
BUT IN ORDER TO SUSTAIN THE
EFFORT, IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
FREEING OUR TERRITORIES, IN
ORDER TO DEFEND THE COUNTRY FOR
ALL THE RUTHLESS ATTACKS FROM
THE RUSSIANS -- TERRORIST
ATTACKS RUEHLI THAT RUSSIANS ARE
PUTTING ON A DAILY BASIS, WE
JUST NEED MORE WEAPONS.
WE KNOW IT'S A LOT TO ASK, BUT
WE CAN WIN.
IT'S NOT ONLY UKRAINE CAN WIN,
IT'S ALL OF US CAN WIN TOGETHER
AND BRING RUSSIA TO JUSTICE.
YES, IT'S CRITICAL AS THE WINTER
APPROACHING TO HAVE THE PACKAGES
OF THE SUPPORT WHICH WERE
ALREADY APPROPRIATED BY CONGRESS
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONGRESS AND ASKING THE CONGRESS
TO REVIEW THE ADDITIONAL
PROPOSAL THAT BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AS ALREADY
SUBMITTED TO CONGRESS FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO UKRAIN